بالامس توصلنا مع اداره المستشفى ابلغنا
بان المستشفى امن وبالامس ايضا تقريبا بعد
صلاه المغرب او قبل صلاه المغرب القى
طائرات الاحتلال مناشير على هذا المربع
وطالبوا الناس بالاخلاء الان الناس كما
ترون تشاهدون يعني جاهزين ويعني ينتظرون
ساعه حددها جيش
الاحتلال حددوا طريق البحر شارع البحر كي
يخلوا منه ولكن كما نسمع الان اشتباكات
عنيفه حضور الان في الشارع الذي ستتجه منه
هؤلاء النازحون الناس الوضع صعب الناس
يعني زي ما انتم شايفين ابنائهم
اطفالهم لا اكل لا طعام لا شراب لا غطاء
للاطفال الاطفال رضع في يد امهاتهم لا
حليب لا الوضع صعب الناس مرضى في ناس مرضى
الان على كسهم نحن نطالب الصليب الاحمر
بالتوجه الى هذا المكان لانه المكان مقتض
بالنازحين
حتى يعني يحموا الناس ويتوجه بالناس الى
المكان
الامن
ه